in the previous video we learned how we
can find the cube roots of numbers in
exponential form but what if the numbers
are large and are not in exponential
form well we use the prime factorization
method say we want to find the cube root
of 216 our aim is to reduce this number
to its prime factors we write the number
here and draw lines like these now we
think of one prime number that is a
factor of 216 we know that 2 is a factor
of 216 so we write a 2 here and we
divide 216 by 2 and write the quotient
here
that is 108 2 multiplied by 108 gives us
216 so we continue with the same
procedure we think of a prime factor
that is a factor of 108 well 108 is also
divisible by 2 and 2 x 54 gives us 108
again since 2 is a factor of 54 we write
2 here and write 27 here as 2 x 27
equals 54 we stop when we get a prime
number here 27 is not a prime number and
hence we continue with the same process
now the prime number that is a factor of
27 is 3 so we write 3 here 3 x 9 equals
27 and we know that 9 equals 3 x 3 this
is where we stop we stop when we see a
prime number here so we have reduced 216
into its prime factors 216 will equal
the product of all these numbers we can
write cube root of 216 as cube root of 2
x 2 x 2 x 3 x 3 x 3 remember do not
forget to include the prime number which
is left at the bottom
so what do we do now if you remember
correctly in squares we made pairs of
same numbers and chose one from each
group in cubes we make groups of three
same numbers and again choose one from
each group hence to find cube root of
216 we group the three twos together and
the three threes together and from each
group we pick just one number and
multiply them so from the first group we
pick two and from the second group we
pick three and after we multiply them we
get six
hence the cube root of 216 equals six so
now we know that once we reduce the
numbers to its prime factors the task is
very simple we make groups of three and
choose one number from each group and
multiply them and it's a good idea to
memorize the cubes of numbers from 1 to
10 I am talking about the cubes and not
the cube roots why do I say this it's
because you'll be able to find the cube
roots of large numbers in a matter of
few seconds maybe even 5 seconds and
when I say large I mean numbers up to
even 6 digits long we will see that in
coming videos keep watching and keep
learning